[Musik]
ich habe über die letzten anderthalb
jahre versuchte streetwear brands
gründen wir mussten produzenten suchen
eine richtung und identität für die
brenn finden und uns durch diverse
sampling prozesse kämpfen neben shooting
versand und dem ganzen anderen kram aber
vor allem immer wieder probleme lösen
mit denen wir niemals gerechnet hätten
wie wir das alles gemacht haben wie ihr
das auch machen könnt und passt jetzt am
ende dabei heraus gekommen ist erfahrt
ihr in diesem video
[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen zur perfekten nach anderthalb
jahren ist es tatsächlich so weit meine
eigenen klamotten komm raus diesen
freitag vierter dritter es wird ein
absolutes fest den gesamten prozess vom
design produktion und so weiter alle
probleme all das habe ich die letzten
anderthalb jahre mit der kamera
begleitet und das hier ist dabei
rausgekommen und bevor ich euch jetzt
langweile ich hab ein kleines team
zusammengestellt aus leuten die mehr
ahnung von textilproduktion haben als
ich an der produktion gesucht und sei
nach istanbul geflogen wir sind jetzt in
düsseldorf am flughafen machen uns auf
den weg nach east haben wohl das erste
mal textilproduktion abchecken erste mal
richtig sehen wie das funktioniert ich
bin super gespannt wir haben
verschiedene termine um lange probiert
das ganze zu machen und haben es lange
vor uns hergeschoben jetzt müssen wir
aber beim letzten jahr lang darauf
gewartet ich bin so verdammt gegen
istanbul und dann schauen wir uns da
verschiedene produktionen rein und alles
an was wir für die textilproduktion
brauchen angefangen bei der rom
baumwolle werden uns für baumwolle
entschieden die komplett aus der türkei
kommt und dann in istanbul verarbeitet
wird und das ist quasi das wir
eingestiegen sind also aus baumwolle
wirklich stoff machen das ganze läuft
mit riesigen maschinen die unendlich
viel geld kosten ihr seht dass die
drehen sich hier im kreis und da wird im
endeffekt der stoff gewebt und wie
vermutlich viele von euch wissen ist die
grammaturen nicht gleich indikator für
qualität das ist eben eine synergie aus
so vielen verschiedenen faktoren wie
gepard der die grund baumwolle für die
man sich entscheidet und noch ganz viel
anderes hier in der produktion haben uns
eben auch angeguckt wie ist zu
verschiedenen sparten kommen dann
geguckt wie die maschinen umgebaut
werden und uns dann natürlich angeschaut
wie die fertigen stoffe sich anfühlen
was es für fertige verschiedene stoffe
gibt die gibt es auch nochmal große
unterschiede man kann auf stock stoffe
zurückgreifen also stoffe die einfach
viel benutzt werden die dann die ganze
zeit produziert werden und bei denen
fabrikanten im lager liegen oder man
entscheidet sich dafür eben stoff
wirklich von grund auf selbst zu
gestalten mit zu gestalten mit zu
entscheiden wieder gewählt wird um so
weit grundsätzlich kann man sie aber für
alle steps in der textilproduktion
merken desto früher man in den
entscheidungsprozess mit einsteigen will
desto detailreiche alles sein soll wenn
man den stoff gewebt und die kombination
aus der baumwolle direkt von anfang an
mit entscheiden will dann wird es
deutlich schwieriger und natürlich
werden auch die mindestabnahme größer
und alles wird insgesamt teuer für viele
produktionen würde sich natürlich nicht
lohnen oder für keine produktion für 150
t shirts und komplett eigenen stoff zu
entwickeln häufig heißt es dann also
einen guten mittelweg finden zwischen
hoher qualität hohem detailreichtum und
irgendwie auch noch einen bezahlbaren
produkt so dass alle im endeffekt sind
und nach diesem step fängt schon an dass
es in verschiedene richtungen gehen kann
es ist nicht fest dass der stoff auf der
weberei als allererstes geschneidert
wird oder als allererstes eingefärbt als
erstes bedruckt und dann geschneidert
oder als erstes geschneidert und dann
bedruckt da gibt es super viele
verschiedene möglichkeiten ich habe mich
selbst ausprobiert so ein bisschen in
reihenfolge zu bringen das heißt aber
nicht dass die produktion grundsätzlich
in dieser reihenfolge stattfinden muss
wir sind danach in die färberei gefahren
wo wir uns angeschaut haben was ist für
verschiedene veredelungsprozess oder
einfärbt prozesse für unsere stoffe t
shirts und den ganzen anderen kram gibt
vermutlich vielen von euch was haben uns
angeschaut es wird tatsächlich mit
steinen in so großen trommeln gewaschen
damit dieser unregelmäßige und doch
regelmäßige effekt damit zustande kommt
hier entscheidet man sich dann auch
quasi dafür wie der stoff sich im
endeffekt anfühlt will man ein weicheres
tragegefühl willmann härteres
tragegefühl will man so eine [ __ ]
oberfläche da gibt es unendlich viele
verschiedene möglichkeiten und darum
muss dann jeder selber wissen was im
budget ist und was man gerne haben
möchte und genau deswegen ist es wichtig
in die einzelnen produktionsstandorte zu
fahren häufig gibt es dann showrooms und
die produktion zeigen was sie alles
können was sie an ihm raten das sehr
wichtig natürlich auf die leute zuhören
die seit jahren erfahrung haben und
nichts anderes machen als einzufärben
oder zu schneidern und mit den leuten zu
sprechen und gemeinsam sich für das
perfekte produkt zu entscheiden wie
mache ich das mit einem stück welchen
gern benutzt für den schritt damit er
sich in den verkaufsprozess wirklich mit
einfärben lässt nimmt die sagt bestimmte
kann die farbe an es ist wichtig dass
alles durchzusprechen und tatsächlich
auch die samples wirklich zu bekommen zu
testen mal zu waschen und zu schauen wie
sich das alles verhält damit man weiß
was man im endeffekt gestellt eine
bestellung über mehrere tausend t shirts
abzusetzen bei einem produkt was man
sich vielleicht cool vorstellt was im
endeffekt dann aber gar nicht so ist wie
man es wirklich haben möchte wäre
natürlich verteilt istanbul ist voll von
textilproduktion das merkt man die leute
leben dass die leute atmen das und
deswegen ist wichtig da zu sein den
leuten zuzuhören und so viel mitzunehmen
es gilt ich will nicht einfach irgendwas
produzieren die dateien nach istanbul
schicken und die fertigen produkte im
karton bekommen sondern ich möchte dahin
und möchte das alles wirklich erleben um
zu viel mitnehmen wie es in kurzer zeit
eben geht nachdem wir dort also alles
weitere besprochen hatten uns für
bestimmte veredelung daten entschieden
haben sind wir weiter in die druckerei
gefangen was für mich der schönste und
beeindruckend zu papa wir haben uns in
der ersten kollektion nur für siebdruck
und stück entschieden jetzt gerade hier
in der druckerei siebdruckerei gesehen
von mir schon über all die verschiedenen
rahmen ich weiß vom prinzip her wie das
funktioniert diese produktion her kann
aber eine menge sachen von der ich noch
nie gehört habt super viele verschiedene
verfahren wegen sehr beeindruckend sind
ich bekomme jetzt gleich hier nochmal
gezeigt wie das alles belichtet wird wie
das professionell aussieht ich habe das
immer mal wieder zu hause im kleinen
kleinen rahmen selber probiert aber das
ist noch mal ein ganz anderes level
super viele verschiedene aufwendige
verfahren mit verschiedenen mustern
forscher hatten verschiedene deckend
haben verläufen es wirklich was ist was
komplett anderes sehr sehr beeindruckend
und hier entstehen dann aber werden dann
im endeffekt quasi die designs gehabt
der sack reis um siebdruck in zwei
sätzen ganz einfach zu erklären im
prinzip hat man einen rahmen bei dem man
sich entscheiden muss wo farbe im
endeffekt durch kommen soll und wo nicht
das wird dann mit seiner blauen emotion
bestrichen belichtet und ausgewaschen
man wird der rahmen in so eine spinne
eingespannt um entweder bei einem
einfarbigen druck viele textilien
gleichzeitig drücken zu können oder
verschiedene ebenen mit verschiedenen
farben zu produzieren auch hier war es
sehr cool die leute haben sich echt zeit
für uns genommen und uns dass alles
ordentlich erklärt siebdruck hatte ich
auch schon mal zu hause gemacht einfach
um so ein gefühl dafür zu bekommen
dort ist natürlich noch mal was ganz
anderes die leute sind super
professionell und konnten uns wirklich
noch viel mehr dazu erzählen also
eigentlich schon boston mit farb-
dichtigkeit die mit bestimmten 7 möglich
ist allgemein kann ich euch raten
einfach viel im internet zuschauen es
gibt videos zu allen verschiedenen druck
arten es gibt leute die es sich zur
aufgabe gemacht haben euch die
textilproduktion so einfach zu machen
wie es geht und wirklich viele
verschiedene steps zu erklären dazu habe
ich euch ein paar links in die video
beschreibung der pakt schaut herein wenn
ihr euch tiefer gehend zu verschiedenen
textilproduktion steps informieren
wollte von hier aus weiter zur
schneiderei also wirklich da wo die
textilien geschnitten und genäht werden
es war mir eigentlich bewusst ist mir in
dem moment aber erst wirklich wieder
klar geworden alle produkte die wir
haben und alles was ihr so in den
schränken hängen habt ist natürlich hand
geschneidert und hand produziert hier
ist es nicht so dass ein schneider von
vorne bis hinten ein produkt komplett
fertig macht sondern der prozess wird in
einzelnen schritte unterteilt schneider
einst zum beispiel kümmert sich nur um
den rechten ärmel schneider 2 nur um den
linken ärmel und schneider 3 fügt das
dann alles im endeffekt zusammen es
kommt meterware stoff auf so riesigen
rollen an was wir schon aus dem einst
der weberei kennen dann wird ein layout
am rechner erstellt um möglichst wenig
des stoffs zu verschwenden und dann
werden die einzelnen stücke der produkte
gesagt ihr liegt der stoff in ganz
vielen verschiedenen ebenen so dass man
nicht jedes produkt einzeln ausschneiden
müssen nachdem das grundprodukt dann
fertig geschneidert ist geht es an die
details also net label switching labels
das ganze wird auf qualität kontrolliert
gebügelt und verpackt so lange es dann
nicht noch weiter an irgendwelche
anderen produktionsnetz geht das war
unglaublich wichtig für mich das alles
wirklich mit meinen eigenen augen zu
sehen also wie sind die
arbeitsbedingungen läuft das alles mit
rechten dingen zu im endeffekt muss ich
dafür gerade stehen produkte an euch zu
verkaufen und das war die einzige
möglichkeit
wie ich dann wirklich 100 prozent sicher
gehen kann weswegen wir auch nicht nur
einmal sondern mittlerweile dreimal in
istanbul waren man muss sich natürlich
irgendwie viele richtungen entscheiden
wen sieht man am ehesten in den
klamotten welche richtung willmann
verkörpern wo will man sich einfach wie
positionieren ich habe mich tatsächlich
am meisten daran orientiert was mir so
ein bisschen fehlt ich will die sachen
tragen und damit sachen erleben ich will
dass leute in meinen klamotten rausgehen
um verrückte scheiße machen ich habe
keine lust dass das die klamotten dafür
da sind nur zu posen für ins tor sondern
die sollen wirklich funktionieren und
benutzt werden und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch erster die richtung
wie ich einschlagen wollte genauso
wollte ich uns auch im shooting
positionieren ich hab ein paar jungs
eingepackt darunter so ziemlich die
verrücktesten gehe ich finden konnte pro
zkrd
fans die free running machen captain of
dracula aus paris dort sei also leute
die genau das verkörpern was ich will
während die einen auf irgendwelchen
dächern unterwegs waren waren die
anderen skaten oder eben wer parcours
machen und genau so hatte ich mir das
vorgestellt ich hatte keine lust models
buchen studio zu buchen um dann
dieselben charakterlosen bilder zu
machen die ihr bei jeder anderen brennt
schon gesehen habe ich wollte dass die
klamotten genau da ankommen wo sie
meines erachtens 10 gehören irgendwie
auf die straße und an die körper von
leuten die irgend eine geile scheiße
machen und natürlich auch hier weiß ich
nichts aus der hand geben kann habe ich
den großteil der bilder selber gemacht
wir werden wahrscheinlich ein sponsoring
team dieses jahr noch auf die beine
stellen je nachdem wie es mit der band
läuft weil ich gerne leute dabei
unterstützen will ihre videos zu
produzieren vielleicht auch vollzeit
sachen ausführen zu können die
eigentlich überhaupt kein geld abwerfen
erst der link in der video beschreibung
findet ihr den ins account da findet ihr
weitere infos zu preisen zu zeiten da
könnt ihr alle klamotten schon sehen
bevor ich in zwei tagen kollektions
vorstellungsvideo mache natürlich lief
aber nicht alles reibungslos wie das
shooting ich habe anderthalb jahre
dieses video hier gedreht um paar
klamotten zu produzieren was hat er so
lang gedauert das problem an der sache
mein größtes problem und vermutlich auch
euer größtes problem wenn ihr eine neue
grand könnten volt ist dass die
mindestabnahmemengen ziemlich hoch ist
wenn ich also ein pulli produzieren
möchte und der produzent sagt du musst
mindestens 350 davon ab dann habe ich in
dieser kollektion immer nur dass das
minimum genommen was ging einfach weil
ich kein unnötiges risiko eingehen will
und weil vielleicht ja die leute
überhaupt gar keinen bock darauf haben
wir morgen von mir zu kaufen damit
rutscht man und das ist ganz natürlich
auf der prioritätenliste natürlich unter
jede andere person unter jedem kunden
eine größere bestellung absetzt dazu
kommt eine ziemlich schwierige
wirtschaftliche lage in der türkei und
all das in kombination hat dazu geführt
dass wir wirklich neun oder zehn monate
jetzt auf die produktion unserer
klamotten gewartet haben allgemein habe
ich natürlich dass die brend wachsen
können dass die produkte euch so
gefallen dass es von uns positiv
angenommen wird und wir in zukunft eine
größere stückzahl bestellen können damit
mehr leute was bekommen können und damit
wir verrückte sachen ausprobieren können
damit unsere stellung bei der produktion
besser wird und wir häufiger sachen
genießen können ich glaube tatsächlich
dass der anfang einer jeden brennt
wirklich am härtesten ist und es
deutlich einfacher wird wenn man mehr
stückzahlen macht man hat viel mehr
freiheiten noch weiter ins detail zu
gehen aber da haben wir uns ständig
lumpen lassen das werdet ihr alles noch
in kollektions vorstellungsvideo singen
und zum abschluss noch eine sache ich
weiß dass gerade super verpönt und
wahrscheinlich die schwierigste
situation ist als youtube anne brandt
haus zu bringen viele leute haben das
gemacht viele leute an keinen bock mehr
darauf dass irgendwelche youtuber sagen
sie haben eine fashion band gegründet
das ist aber so ein bisschen allgemeine
ansicht von mir auf dinge die freiheit
alles zu machen worauf man lust hat ist
so viel mehr wert als die meinung von
irgendwem anders sich juli mit mit
sachen zu beschäftigen auf die man lust
hat da hinzufliegen herzblut in projekt
zu stecken und das zu machen worauf man
lust hat ist so viel mehr wert als die
die meinungen schon irgendwem anders
dazu ich habe den spaß meines lebens
gehabt mit kumpels gemeinsam an diesem
projekt zu arbeiten
in istanbul zu sein zu hause zu sein uns
den kopf zerbrechen man könne dann
probieren das bestmögliche heraus zu
kommen ich hoffe natürlich dass bei den
meisten von euch das alles positiv
aufgenommen wird dass ihr spaß an den
produkten haben dass wir spaß an diesem
video hatte und ihr gegeben und halt was
davon mitnehmen konnte um die verstanden
habt das ist wirklich ein herzensprojekt
von mir eigentlich hatte ich wollte
dieses video 30 oder 35 minuten lang
werden zu lassen habe mich dann aber
doch dagegen entschieden weil es völlig
unnötig gewesen wäre jeden einzelnen
produktionsprozess im detail zu erklären
es gibt schon leute die sich in youtube
deutschland genau das zur aufgabe
gemacht haben folgen beispielsweise
zeigt euch wie ihr produktions dateien
erstellen können designs erstellen
können produktionen findet super viel
kram wird erklärt und ich habe ich den
link in der video beschreibung gepackt
wenn ihr euch also wirklich weiter rein
arbeiten wollte und ihr euch im detail
interessiert wie sachen laufen check-in
link in der video beschreibung ab und
lasst euch ein bisschen liebe da die
klamotten drogen am 4 jetzt kommenden
freitag um 18 uhr in den nächsten tagen
kommt noch eine kollektions
vorstellungen noch einen trailer wenn
ihr aber schon ein bisschen von dem
kranken scheiß sehen wollten wir in
paris gemacht haben dann checkt auf ins
tor vorbei erst an der video
beschreibung da findet ihr auch weitere
infos zu den preisen und einfach detail
fotos der produkte ich weiß jeder sagt
das aber ich würde euch tatsächlich
raten um 1850 da zu sein wenn ihr was
bekommen wollt damit wir die freiheit
haben die nächsten kollektionen auch
schon zu planen und zu produzieren
mussten wir das einfach ein bisschen
geringer halten weil man ist sich sonst
wirklich nicht hätte leisten können so
sehr in vorleistung zu gehen das
bedeutet aber gleichzeitig auch die
nächsten drei kollektionen sind schon
geplant und wir haben wirklich wirklich
crazy produkte also es wird nur
verrückter ich hoffe euch hat das video
gefallen das gerne leica vergesst nicht
den kanal zu abonnieren und dann sehen
wir uns in den nächsten tagen zu
kollektions vorstellungen oder trailer
oder auf installiert gutshot